oh i'm so happy to see you guys
hi hi you guys
hey i'm so happy to see you both as well
hi
i'm so excited to be celebrating and
talking about this show i can't stop
watching it jessica biel you've been
nominated for an emmy before for the
sinner
i
believe
with all of my heart that this will be
your next emmy nomination
oh my goodness geez
i really do you're so incredible
in this show and melanie i also believe
you will be nominated for an emmy for
this show
also just had the esteemed pleasure as
we all did watching you win your award
um at the critics choice and then you
get up there and you kind of do this
thing that goes
viral and wild afterwards because you
thanked your nanny
yeah i mean
she's i was kind of surprised that it
became like a thing afterwards because
when i think about the people who are
the biggest part of my life who make it
possible for me to work it's my husband
and my nanny she's just
the coolest person in the world and she
works so hard and how lucky am i that i
have a person like that taking care of
my child so i can really
go to work and concentrate and not be
worried i mean what
what an unfortunate thing melanie i
really think you might have opened a new
door for all of us women to acknowledge
people in our inner circle in a
different way and i thank you for that
thank you so much for saying that thanks
i fully agree i mean i think what a
beautiful thing to do and
there's
no way my life
either would exist without the two
wonderful nannies that that take care of
my beautiful kids so thank you melanie
and thank you to everyone out there
who's
making everyone else's life you know
possible outside of the house we could
not do it without the support teams that
we have impossible and we shouldn't be
ashamed to you know to to tell the truth
about that i don't think well it's funny
you know we do live in a different more
modern society and the show that you're
doing
um you know is a bit aesthetically of a
period piece
it's a true story you guys this is one
of the most eerie
suspenseful
it gives my flesh tingles and makes it
crawl in all the right ways it's so good
how did you make a show this good it's
intimate but it just
ah
ah what was your approach to this show
jessica
there there was a real
sense of uh
importance in creating the the like
mundanity of a suburban life especially
back in 1980 in a place like wiley texas
and to sit in those very
normal
somewhat eerie
strange isolating you know experiences
and to really see specifically these two
women
in their separate
but
um
you know their mindsets which are very
different but also i really believe
going through very similar issues
um with feeling alone and feeling maybe
a lot of regret and a lot of resentment
about how their life has turned out and
i think so many of us can
can really
we can really empathize and understand
that feeling and there are choices made
like melanie when you're sitting in your
house
you're alone and the baby keeps crying
and it's like there's no trickery it's
the
onset of a baby crying repeatedly
throughout the day and the night in
different intervals and i'm like this
has so many
layers to it how did you
i mean how did you do it
well i mean i felt her very deeply in my
soul i mean she was somebody who was a
complicated person not the easiest
person and a few people that i talked to
believed that she had kind of
undiagnosed postpartum depression
because it wasn't really discussed in
1980 and she was really struggling
it just moved me so much that she had no
one to turn to
and it's part of the heartbreak of the
story is because she felt at a certain
point like she could turn to candy as a
friend like she had one friend finally
and then oh yeah yeah she could
[Music]